This is a hilarious and sad and tragic and
a completely predictable story all at once.
Fox News removed Donald Trump from a picture
with Jeffrey Epstein and Ghislain Maxwell.
Now he.
Lane Maxwell.
Yeah.
I just because I mentioned their names, this
video will be democratized.
But it's an important story.
Glenn Maxwell is the former girlfriend of
the late Jeffrey Epstein.
Allegedly the recruiter of many of the women
who Epstein is accused of sexually assaulting.
And after a long I guess you could call it
an absence, at least from the public eye.
Maxwell has been arrested and is scheduled
to be in court this Friday.
Now, Donald.
He's very connected to Jeffrey Epstein, we
have countless pictures of them together,
there's the video of Trump and Eppstein sort
of evaluating young women who were dancing
at a party during the 1990s.
Trump and Epstein were accused of rape by
the same then 13 year old girl.
That case was eventually dropped.
Take a look at this video in which Fox News
is doing a story about the arrest of Julian
Maxwell.
And they actually Photoshop out.
They just cropped Trump out of a picture with
Eppstein.
And just a disclaimer.
This is very visual.
So if you're just listening, you're only going
to hear what they are saying.
But what you will see on screen is Melania
Trump then now Scibelli before she was married,
Ghislain Maxwell Eppstein.
And then there's just somebody who's been
cropped out and that's Donald Trump.
Take a look at this.
Against Maxwell.
Which one are you focused on most and how
does the timeline of all three play out?
Well, thank you for having me.
And that's a very we call we call that a compound
question.
There's a lot going on in that question to
kind of decompress.
But, yeah, I would say that all three of those
things are there, three different areas that
we're all looking at.
Obviously, we have the civil case against
Epstein.
The criminal case against Miss Maxwell that
now if you look at the original picture, which
is widely available, of course, you see the
four of them.
It's Trump along with Melania and Jeffrey
Epstein and Ghislain Maxwell.
So clearly, this is an attempt to rewrite
history and remove the friendship of Trump
and Epstein.
Right.
Well, Fox says it was just an innocent mistake.
Didn't mean to just an accident.
Check this out.
They put out a quote saying on Sunday, July
five, a report on Ghislain Maxwell during
Fox News Channel's America's News headquarters
mistakenly eliminated President Donald Trump
from a photo alongside Melania Epstein and
Maxwell.
We regret the error.
It was just a coincidence, right?
It was.
They mistakenly cropped exactly Donald Trump
out of that picture.
How do you mistakenly edit someone out of
a picture and not notice that the person you
happen to edit out is the president of the
United States right now?
And one thing that's actually a little weird
to me is that Fox used that picture to begin
with.
Why even use that one?
Because there's plenty of stock photos all
over the place of Eppstein with Elaine Maxwell.
And someone e-mailed me an interesting hypothesis,
which is, you know why they did this, David?
They picked a picture that Trump was in but
cropped him out to intimidate Trump.
Trump's been going hard at Fox News lately,
saying that they're falling.
You know, that you got to watch Newsmax and.
Oh, and Fox is bad now.
Fox is sending Trump a message.
We have pictures of you with Eppstein.
OK, we're cropping you out this time.
But if you keep going after us, this is the
hypothesis.
We'll put out the pictures where you're not
cropped out.
I don't know.
It's an interesting idea.
Is it Fox trying to portray Trump more positively
by cropping him out?
Is it Trump being protected by Fox News?
Is it an intimidation signal?
We don't really know.
But what is important to remember is that
these were people who were around each other
frequently.
Maxwell now has been moved to the Metropolitan
Detention Center in Brooklyn, New York, scheduled
to appear in court on Friday.
Now, I just I want to get this out of the
way now.
If Maxwell is found dead while in custody
and it appears she committed suicide, there
would be no doubt that something is up.
Right.
Are people on board with me on this one?
I'm just getting it out ahead of time just
in case.
And of course, we hope that that doesn't happen.
Just want to think ahead as to what your reaction
would be if that were to take place.
We'll have continued coverage of crop gate
on our Instagram page at David Pakman show.
And if you want something lighter, there is
a full tour of my backyard Urban Garden on
my Instagram page right now at David Pakman,
T